do you think that a director can be an
effective director if they themselves
have never taken acting classes or just
maybe one or two little one-day
workshops do you think they really need
to dive into taking a full semester or
several you know a year of acting
classes to really know what it's like to
be the person that they're directing
again you've done 12 questions in my
mind I heard one no there's a lot first
of all the first thing you said going
back the first can they be an effective
director without it yeah it's really
where you started or with very
absolutely they can be oh they can okay
it doesn't mean you have to have studied
acting or been an actor do you don't
have to know okay you know there are a
lot of directors who are very good and
very effective without it now that's
because of who they are
and I don't know what all that training
background and history is but looking at
the other side if you want to be the
best director you could ever be then
take an acting class and writing it we
talked about writing it up but take an
acting class and take an acting class
with other actors not an acting class
where it's just two or three directors
trying to learn how to act because that
they'll you'll all hold each other down
but if you get in an acting class with
some actors some really good actors and
so you can experience what it's like to
go through the process you can
experience what it's like to get a
script and start to break down a scene
you can this being what's it like to do
the homework you can experience what
it's like to get up there with another
actor who you don't know what they're
going to do and you're trying to engage
with them and you're trying to engage
with the power of the senior trying to
engage with your character and you can
do this week after week after week after
week now you're getting to experience
what it's like to be an actor now the
important thing here is not how good an
actor you are you could be the world's
worst actor doesn't matter it's the
experience it's getting inside the shoes
of the actor going through that so you
this is what they have to go through
this is the challenges they face your
whole perception of talking to them and
what you're asking them to do will
change because you'll know you can't
just ask them to be angrier that doesn't
work you can't ask them to be more
sympathetic or show you a little more
vulnerability because it doesn't work
you'll understand from your own
experience not just because I said it or
not just because some teacher said it to
you don't do that
you'll understand what works you'll
understand what worked for you and
chances are the things that worked for
you you will start to use those things
when you start talking to actors because
you know it worked for you maybe it'll
work with them very valuable some of our
best directors are actors some of our
best directors come from the theatre one
thing I want to say about the theater
directing since we're on this theater
directing is very different from film
directing because in terms of
relationships with the actors because in
film directing I can direct a scene I
can spend a whole day on the scene and
do the range of performances we talked
about before and get that range and get
enough and then I will build a scene
that works in theatre I have I don't
have that option I have the option of
rehearsing with him and trying a lot of
different things but eventually I have
to get those two actors to a point where
they can do it all by themselves every
night it's a it's much more challenging
way more challenging then film it's a
different it's a different challenge way
more challenging in terms of working
with actors to get them to be able to
repeat something every night or come
close to something or stay authentic
every single night so I highly recommend
besides directors taking acting classes
direct theater and I can say try it
you'll be amazed at how difficult it is
because you have so little control over
those actors so little
so what if an actor thinks I haven't
taken any acting classes but you know I
don't need to I I know human beings I
can I know more about someone than they
know about themselves it doesn't matter
but you watch them and you're observing
the opposite this is a director
directors doing that what are you
observing in a director that says they
don't need acting classes but you're
seeing well as soon as I hear you say
that
pretty much as soon as I hear you say it
I don't need this on you do you know do
you know what I hear resistant arrogance
oh okay
and I also hear fear Oh
a lot of directors I mean our arrogance
yes okay I think I know how to do this
I'm not saying that wrong but the
arrogance is doesn't help you it doesn't
help you because it puts up a barrier
between you and the actors so a lot of
them feel that they know that also the
fear a lot of actors I mean I'm sorry a
lot of directors are afraid of actors
they born admit it but in a statement
like you just said I hear it okay I know
how to do what I do in other words I
don't need to engage with this other
human being on a collaborative
vulnerable level I know it I know how to
talk to them it's just do this like I
took psychology I took this I've you
know I used to be at this I used to be
at that you know I was a life coach I
was away whatever I know how to do that
and I'm saying you're telling me that
you do not want to engage with them on a
one-to-one basis in terms of the
exploration of something that has
absolutely nothing to do with either of
you the thing that has not that is that
has nothing to do with either of you is
a character you're both working together
to create a character and you think you
know so there's there's a fear there's a
resistance a lot of directors are
resistant they don't a lot of directors
don't want to rehearse oh I don't need
to rehearse I just got cast the best
people I can and then I'm fine don't
want to don't want to rehearse why would
they not want
could be two reasons one is they have no
idea what to do in rehearsal now that's
a big part of my job as I teach people
what to actually how to rehearse and
this my whole career started many many
years ago at the Directors Guild me
teaching a list directors how to
rehearse just the simplest thing in the
world now it's not the simplest thing in
the world but that's what I was teaching
and my teaching career started way back
then so a lot of directors don't know
how what to do you know you give them a
rehearsal so let's read it and then they
talk about it and they talk about the
characters and then then what nothing so
that's one problem it's a lot of
directors have not been trained how to
rehearse again speaking of my career for
a moment this is why I have a career
traveling all over the world to film
schools world-class film schools
teaching directors how to rehearse
because they don't have in the film
school someone who knows how to teach
directors how to rehearse so that's one
part and the other part is fear out of
directors fear being seen as inept
unable incapable and this is a big
problem that's a big problem
it's a big problem within the whole film
world directors are supposed to know
everything you're the director you
should know here's an interesting thing
I'm a director's coach and all that
Nidorino I teach directors I consult
with directors and many times I coach
directors and I'm known as the directors
director at all that actors in a film if
there's an actress coach there that's
fine an actor's coach fine
imagine a film they said who is he or
he's the directors coach what he's me
why does he need a coat the whole
perception it's not the directors
problem it's a problem with the
perception the directors supposed to
have all the answers so directors take
that in embrace that concept I'm
supposed to have all the answers so I
have to say I do have all the answers so
I have to say I know what I'm doing I
don't need help many many years ago I
was because I teach of the Directors
Guild a friend of mine who works there
gave me a list of directors that
which is for another seminar of all the
first-time directors people who came to
a first-time directors seminar said mark
I think you might like to have this list
because you're teaching directors I said
great I promoted a workshop to that list
that's a big list and then I had people
in my office just doing follow-up it's
called and one call to one of these
directors I don't know who it was it
doesn't matter and they call and the
director said don't call me why are you
calling me while we're doing this
workshop don't you understand he said I
am a member of the Directors Guild I
don't need a directing workshop now that
is dangerous see that that is him
identifying himself as a as a director
as a member the directors guild like
I've reached a certain level and now I
will cut myself off from anything or
anything that maybe could help me know
there's a lot of directors who believe
that a lot of directors who live there
and that's what leads to the arrogance I
know what I'm doing now I'm fortunate
very fortunate as a directing consultant
and coach to a lot of directors all over
the world because the directors I get to
meet number one who take the workshops
and especially the directors I get to
work with who asked me to consult in
these films because these are the
directors that are open and available
and humble enough to know that they can
learn more and they can expand their
awareness and expand their skills and
the arrogance is not their arrogance is
not there and then they're willing to
learn and these are the directors who
were there all doing very very well now
you